House and Senate Democrats torpedo a
bipartisan coronavirus relief bill
raising an important question if elected
Democrats are in taking the pandemic
seriously why should we we will examine
the political shenanigans and the light
at the end of the economic tunnel then
the mainstream media spread a story of a
man dying from the drug tatted by
President Trump as a possible cure for
coronavirus the only problem with their
story is it's completely false we'll
take a look at what really happened all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael nose show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there is so much to get to today we will
almost certainly not have enough time
but we will try to fit it all in because
there are a lot of political shenanigans
going on behind the scenes before we get
to that got to thank our friends over it
to Kovas you know whenever we get back
to normal in this crazy world of ours I
can't wait to go out to bars and
restaurants and places where other
people are and show off my new to Kovas
cowboy boots which are hand made with
high quality full grain leather by
world-class boot makers they are built
to be comfortable right out of the box
and for every occasion at home in the
office and out on the town to Kovas are
designed to be as fashionable 50 years
from now as they are today and to Kovas
cuts out the middleman sells directly to
you at an honest price so you get
unbelievable quality that you can afford
I love these things I mean you can pull
them off if you are out from the country
or if you're a city slicker like me do
what I did get yourself a pair of two
Kovas cowboy boots today at two Kovas
dot-com slash Knowles kano wles that's
Tec ova s.com slash Knowles do it now
they are so comfortable you don't even
have to break them in they wear great
right out of the box and they look great
too to go viscom slash Knowles
all right Democrats torpedoed the
coronavirus relief bill and there is so
much spin and propaganda going on around
this but really what the Democrats did
is indefensible okay it's it goes beyond
the usual level of partisan tit for that
and directed for that different at and
trying to get your own interests in
there they torpedoed the bill even the
New York Times admitted it so the first
New York Times headline to report on
this said honestly Democrats block
action on 1.8 trillion dollar stimulus
because that's what happened but that
was a little too harsh and the Democrats
wasn't that you can't you're the New
York Times should have allowed to do
that so the second headline read quote
Democrats block action on stimulus plan
seeking worker protections is it still
admitting Democrats blocked it but
they're giving them
or coverage as to why they blocked it
then the third headline partisan divide
threatens deal on rescue bill no it's
not the partisan divide it's the
Democrats you were right the first two
times and really you were right right
just the first time so what did the
Democrats block what was so
objectionable that the Democrats didn't
want to pass it paid sick leave for
workers that was in the bill that's
something usually Democrats are talking
about more than Republicans are so that
shouldn't have been objectionable free
coronavirus testing for everybody
including the uninsured Democrats were
prattling on about that for weeks and
weeks everyone's got to get a test suite
okay fine good everyone gets a test
checks have up to twelve hundred dollars
for Americans making under a hundred
thousand dollars per year that was
Andrew Yang's entire campaign Democrats
have talked about a universal basic
income now for at least a decade and in
some circles for a lot longer than that
well okay now Americans are just getting
direct checks from the government
they're upset about that funding for
food assistance specifically food
assistance for low-income women and
mothers with young children you know
very often Democrats will say that
Republican relief packages or they're
just geared for the rich there are tax
cuts for the rich their welfare for the
rich which is virtually never true but
in this case we're talking about
low-income women and mothers with young
children that's a problem it strengthens
unemployment benefits I thought the
Democrats could get behind that and then
at the heart of the package is a five
hundred billion dollar loan program
billion with a B that would float
businesses that are about to collapse
now you could imagine the Democrats
objecting to that because they say we
don't want a half trillion dollars of
corporate welfare but it's not corporate
welfare it's a loan to keep the
businesses around so the workers still
have jobs so they certainly should be
able to get behind that and as far as
I'm concerned the most objectionable
part of the entire bill is that it costs
two trillion dollars but Democrats love
that stuff you know they proposed the 93
trillion dollar green New Deal they
proposed Liz Warren's fifty two trillion
dollar health care plan so two trillion
that's nothing that's a
up in the bucket and yet the Democrats
torpedo did this was negotiated in good
faith bipartisan both sides of the aisle
and then at the last minute the
Democrats shot it down Senate
Republicans were furious Mitch McConnell
Senate Majority Leader lays out exactly
what happened we had a high level of
bipartisanship in five different working
groups over the last 48 hours where
members who were participating were
reaching agreement and then all of a
sudden the Democratic Leader and the
Speaker of the House shows up and we're
back to square one so there was a high
level of bipartisanship this was not
like most legislation where it's just
written by one party entirely and then
and then passed this really was a good
faith effort and then Schumer and Pelosi
mess it all up the big takeaway here for
me is that Democrats aren't taking this
very seriously they sound like they're
taking it seriously right they're saying
the whole world is going to end
basically if we don't completely lock
down Trump isn't doing enough we need to
nationalize the economy they're actually
suggesting that we'll get to it in a
second we need a national lock down you
hear that from left-wing celebrities out
of Hollywood and yet they can't even get
one relief package through they're
talking a good game but they're not
actually following through with it Susan
Collins who is the classic Senate
moderate she's the one who's you never
know if she's gonna vote with the
Republicans or not she's a squishy
Republican from Maine she was furious
about this talked about the
unprecedented rancor in the Senate over
something that should be so easy to pass
through unbelievably the Democratic
leader objected to my even being able to
speak this morning is that what we've
come to the Democratic leader objected
to our convening at nine o'clock this
morning so that we could begin working
in earnest is that what we've come to
the fact is we have been working on a
bipartisan ever through task force with
both Republicans and Democrats making
very good progress and putting together
a comprehensive package the third
package that we have dealt with this one
is to address and prevent the economic
devastation that is being caused by this
virus we don't have another day we don't
have another day this is a stimulus
package because there is a government
imposed economic shutdown you don't have
18 months to negotiate this thing if you
negotiate this thing for 18 months the
economy is destroyed the way you know
that the Democrats overstepped here
other than the New York Times calling
them out for it albeit briefly is that
another Democrat called the man for it
Mitt Romney
I guess he's nominally a Republican but
you know the guy's pretty squishy even
Mitt Romney was furious he tweeted about
this he tweeted that quote nothing in
the Senate has shocked me until today
standing in the way of a critically
needed rescue package is irresponsible
and reckless Dems say not enough money
to States nearly 200 billion dollars
isn't chump change
hospitals get at least 75 billion so
he's touting some of the advantages of
this bill now ROM Romney expressed his
dissatisfaction on Twitter because
Romney is currently in isolation for
possible exposure to the corona virus
which in itself prompted a pretty funny
Trump response with the critical
stimulus package vote expectation yes
gee that's too bad no no none whatsoever
Trump you would never be sarcastic it's
too bad that's a very funny reaction we
all hope that Romney recovers very
quickly and then we hope that he
continues to self quarantine for another
or I don't know 20 or 25 years or so
still even Mitt Romney totally gets it
on this point but the best showing of
the day came from Ted Cruz we'll get to
that in just one second first I've got
to thank our friends over at keeps
listen you know me
okay I'm not exactly an Olympic athlete
all right I'm not hulking Adonis of a
man necessarily one thing I've always
had going for me with the ladies though
got a nice full head of hair
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 you think it starts
way later than that it doesn't it starts
early but with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and help you keep the hair you have
at half the cost of your local pharmacy
the key here is prevention keeps us up
to 90 percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss but the
sooner you start using keeps the more
hair you're gonna save so you got to act
fast if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps calm slash
Knowles canna wles you will receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
my gift to you you're welcome
ke EP s.com slash Knowles check it out
right now the sooner you get started the
sooner it will start helping you to save
your hair okay the best reaction of the
day much better than Romney much better
than Susan Collins better even than
cocaine Mitch was my good pal from Texas
senator Ted Cruz Fame quote from Rahm
Emanuel President Obama's chief of staff
never let a good crisis go to waste
sadly we're seeing the embodiment of
that cynical approach right now because
all the people out of jobs the Democrats
are using to push what are they pushing
for changing the emission standards on
airplanes
mr. president what the hell do the
emission standards on airplanes have to
do with thousands of people dying in
millions of people out of work in the
Koroma crota virus epidemic right
exactly what is it we'll get to what it
is exactly in the Democrats version of
this bill because it is hilarious I mean
it is it's much I was gonna say it you
could be in a Saturday Night Live sketch
but it's so much funnier than a Saturday
Night Live sketch we'll get to every one
of those things Ted Cruz's point here is
exactly right okay and this is
validating all of us skeptics who have
thought that maybe this pandemic is a
little bit overhyped by the left and by
the media because they're hyping it up
it's going to be the end of the world
but they're not taking it seriously when
it comes to the bills which means they
don't really believe that it's all that
serious now you might just say oh that's
just politics you know this has always
have politics worse both sides are
trying to get an advantage they'll use
any crisis to do it okay I mean I see
the point in principle the thing is
Republicans aren't actually doing that
right now okay and Cruz gets to that
point next don't treat this bill like a
partisan Christmas's and by the way you
know Republicans we've got things we
would like to advance two things I
believe in deeply you know talk about
what I'd like to do I'd like to abolish
the IRS I've campaigned on that all over
the country I'm going to continue
fighting for that but mr. president I'm
not standing here with an amendment
saying as part of this emergency relief
let's abolish the IRS there's a place
for that political and policy discussion
the Democrats are pushing wind and solar
tax credits
mr. president what in the hell does a
windmill have to do with this crisis
other than there's some Democratic
lobbyists getting fat and rich that's it
there are a lot of Democratic lobbyists
getting fatless stuffing this over 1,000
page Democratic alternative to the bill
I love that Cruz made this point here it
shows you his skill as a debater it
shows you his rhetorical skill as he
says look you're gonna
pretend that this is just politics on
both sides Republicans have things that
we want okay I want to abolish the IRS I
want to cut taxes significantly
I want a stronger preservation of our
culture I want stronger social laws as
well I want to abolish abortion I want
to do all that kind of stuff I'm not
exploiting a pandemic relief bill to do
it
Democrats you are so often what the left
does in order to make their argument is
they they just insinuate that you're as
bad as they are right so that they don't
ever have to rise up to a standard
they'll just drag you down where they
are but that is not what's happening
here this is not even so what our
Democrats trying to cram into this bill
Cruz got into some of it up there if the
bill is 1119 pages long it focuses on
the very important things during
pandemic pay equity so pay equity pay
equity is based on this incorrect
premise that businesses are paying
people much less money based on their
race or sex or sexual preferences or
whatever name the victim group that's
what they're paying them less money on
no of course this doesn't make any sense
because if businesses could save 26
percent by only hiring women do you know
what businesses would do they would only
hire women do you really believe that
businesses whose entire purpose is to
maximize profits for their shareholders
do you really think that they're so
bigoted they're so sexist or racist or
the sister that is that they would
willingly give up 26% no nobody really
believes that do you really think that
people based on their race could make I
don't I don't know whatever figure the
Democrats are touting right now but call
it the same number seventy five cents on
the dollar do you really think that if
businesses could hire only black people
and pay them seventy five cents on the
dollar that they wouldn't just do that
of course they would but these
statistics are all completely
manipulated by the left I mean in the
case of the so-called gender pay gap
it's been shown time and time again when
you remove differences of Education
differences of experience hoursworked
the pay gap virtually disappears so pea
that's an important thing during a
pandemic corporate board diversity who
cares
not me but it's got to go in there I
guess mandatory early voting so it's the
federal government forcing the states to
allow for early voting because it makes
it a lot easier for Democrats to dig up
all those corpses in Ohio and get them
to the polls to vote for their
candidates mandatory same-day voter
registration why have voter registration
at all we don't need it if you can do it
same day and if the federal government
forces the states to do it same day by
the way the states the individual states
are supposed to control voting and yet
in this case major power grab by the
left a bail out for the post office okay
I guess the left loves the post office
for some reason gonna throw that bail
out in their student loan bailout of
$30,000 per borrower no reason for that
whatsoever it's something they've talked
about during the presidential campaign
they're trying to exploit this natural
disaster for that purpose limit on
deportations they're you know it's
amazing that we're locking down not only
the borders were severely limiting air
travel we are locking people in their
own apartments behind walls to keep out
the virus but we're not going to deport
foreign nationals who are in our country
illegally great makes a lot of sense
right
provisions enforcing sections of the
green New Deal that's also in the
Democrat bill and then taxpayer handouts
to abortionists that's the Democrats
super serious bill I told you what was
in the Republicans version of the bill
well actually the bipartisan version of
the bill it was stuff that frankly
Democrats probably could get behind more
than Republicans could but bipartisan
pandemic got to do it this thing it's a
joke they're not taking it seriously and
this gets to my main point today my main
takeaway from all of these shenanigans
this pandemic by just the evidence
presented by the left has been overhyped
and it's time to start getting back to
normal so President Trump is called for
putting partisan interests aside getting
the relief bill passed
now Congress must demonstrate the same
bipartisanship again and joined together
to pass this
bill is written and avoid playing any
more partisan games they have to get
together and just stop with the partisan
politics and I think that's happening I
got a call a little while ago I guess
they're getting closer it should go
quickly and must go quickly it's not
really a choice they'd have a choice to
have to make a deal you should not be a
time for political agendas but rather
one for focusing solely and squarely on
the needs of the American people we are
going to save American workers and we're
going to save them quickly great so
that's Trump's priority just get the
money back into the economy get the
economy cooking a little bit again so it
doesn't completely collapse how is the
Left responding to that they want to
nationalize businesses even on this most
basic level of the relief package the
left is trying to exploit this for a
radical desire that they've had for over
a hundred years that is having the
government take control of the
businesses fortunately though when they
suggested that through our reporter at
this White House briefing President
Trump smacked him down when it comes to
the defense production Act we know that
governor's across the country all day
today we're pleading with you to
eautiful to utilize the DPA why not use
it now if that would answer their pleas
for help
but we are using it now the fact that I
signed it it's in effect but you know
we're a country not based on
nationalizing our business call a person
over in Venezuela ask them how did
nationalization of their businesses work
out not too well the concept of
nationalizing our business is not a good
concept it's not a good concept
absolutely not I just I would like to
apologize I refer to that reporter is a
him it's actually her though perhaps now
I'm assuming her gender and maybe that's
a whole other problem but his answer is
exactly right here look at Venezuela if
you want to look at nationalization we
are not going to that Trump clearly has
the right instincts here and then the
nice thing is he's able to articulate
why I'll tell you why as Peter said we
may have to use it someplace along the
chain but we're getting calls here's the
beauty of it if we go out and we want
let's say masks we don't know who to
call learn mask but Hanes who makes
things of cotton various elements lots
of things it's a great company they
called us and they said we're going to
make millions of masks we got a call
today from 3m there's a big article
today the head of 3m they're going to
make tremendous products and they're
more or less in that business and if
they're not like for instance General
Motors spoke to us Ford spoke to us
about doing ventilators the beauty is
they're calling us if you go the
National rough nationalisation route
we're gonna tell a company to make a
ventilator they don't even know what a
ventilator is so has the whoo flu
freakout gone too far Trump clearly
articulating why we can't take these
radical new measures why we can't go
even further down this rabbit hole of
shutdown and nationalization on the one
side you've got Trump saying maybe we
got to get back to normal maybe we've
got to try to you know obviously protect
public health but not totally implode
our economy on the other side you have
the left which is extending the crisis
right by not passing the stimulus
package they are extending the crisis by
trying to fit in all this crazy economy
destroying legislation and there they
are extending the crisis by suggesting
that we nationalize industries they're
extending the crisis so those are the
two opinions do we start to lighten up a
little bit here
you got Trump on that side or do we
double down lock down the country stop
the economy grind everything even
further to a halt
that's what's the left is saying
fortunately it's not just Trump on the
side of saying maybe we need to get the
economy going again
doctor foul Qi the sainted doctor foul
Qi our public health dictator who tells
us how to live I'm I'm really just
mocking his position here I think doctor
foul Qi has actually done a very good
job and doctor foul Qi even he is saying
we can't
completely locked down the economy he
says quote if you knock down the economy
completely and disrupt infrastructure
you may be causing health issues so it's
not it's not just that people are gonna
suffer health issues if we don't lock
down they might suffer health issues
because we've locked down might suffer
unintended consequences for people who
need to be able to get to places and
can't if you lock down everything now
you're going to crash the whole society
so now on the maybe we need to lighten
up maybe we need to be more careful here
you've got Trump and you've got doctor
foul Qi on the other side you've got
Nancy Pelosi and the Dems but it's not
just Trump and doctor foul Qi on the
side of maybe we need to lighten up you
even have I kid you not
the New York Times and who's writing in
the New York Times a Yale professor so
now you've got the public health
representative the expert
you've got the New York Times which is
the left-wing outlet you've got a
professor from Yale which is a very
left-wing school all saying the same
thing the headline from the New York
Times
written by David Katz is our fight
against coronavirus worse than the
disease that's almost word-for-word what
President Trump tweeted out a couple of
days ago and Katz makes this point he
shows that in war you know there are two
kinds of military action there is
intense you know carpet-bombing action
and then there is a surgical strike
which way should we try to respond to
the coronavirus so far we've been just
carpet bombing the entire economy
forcing everybody to be locked down shut
down completely no businesses are open
basically and then the other alternative
is what dr. Katz proposes herd immunity
you tell people who are very at-risk to
stay home the rest of the people take
precautions but go about their business
then maybe people get the virus but
statistically they're very unlikely to
have bad reaction to it and we're death
god forbid and then they're immune then
it's much
we're difficult for them to pass it
along and then we just move on as we do
with every other kind of virus Trump
ouchy the New York Times
Yale professor very disparate group you
might call it bipartisan on the side of
let's move on and you've got Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer saying keep
this all shut down let's drag out this
misery as long as we can there is ample
evidence all around us that this has
gone too far and by the way we may have
found a cure we'll get to that in a
second there's a very promising cure and
the media are lying through their teeth
about it we'll get to that first if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content called all-access live you
should head over to Daley wire comm and
check it out
Jeremy had been kicked it off last week
then we all did live streams each day
over at Daily wire calm I've done two of
them now we will continue all of this
week at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
it's a relaxed show it's very easy it's
like a webcam and we're hanging out this
is not a highly produced news show we
are just going to be there with you well
you are totally quarantined the show is
intended for all access members but for
a limited time we've opened it up to all
of our members so let us know what you
think of it if you're around at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. pacific tonight join us
on the all-access live show over at daly
wire.com we got a whole lot more to get
to so don't go anywhere
we may have found a cure for the corona
virus we don't know it hasn't been
clinically tested it is not approved by
the FDA but it looks like an
anti-malaria drug called hide
hydroxychloroquine it's hard to
pronounce that one
president Trump struggled with
pronouncing it at the press conference
the other day hydroxychloroquine is
showing a lot of promise for treating
the corona virus now the media don't
want you to know that so why do we think
that this is showing promise well just
anecdotally it has there's a 52 year old
man who got the corona virus he spent
days in the ICU he could couldn't
breathe on his own he was struggling he
thought that he was on death's door he
actually called friends and family and
said goodbye to them because he thought
that he wouldn't make it until the next
morning then a friend of his mentioned
hydroxychloroquine okay he spoke to the
doctors the doctors said this hasn't
been tested yet he said please there's
my last chance within a half an hour he
gets the drug she has a very intense
reaction to the drug the next morning he
felt totally fine so President Trump has
talked about this now the mainstream
media are running this narrative that
people are self-medicating with
hydroxychloroquine and dying as a result
of it this from an NBC News NBC tweets
out Arizona man dies after ingesting
chloroquine in an attempt to prevent
corona virus there are no drugs approved
to try to prevent or treat the new
corona virus self-medicating to prevent
the corona virus can be dangerous and
possibly deadly trouble is that is a
false news story it's fake news it's a
lie the man did not ingest this new
medicine that they're touting as a
possible treatment for corona virus
here's from the story itself I'm not
even giving you outside information this
is from the actual NBC news story quote
an Arizona man has died after ingesting
chloroquine phosphate so not chloroquine
not hydroxychloroquine chloroquine
phosphate believing it would protect him
from becoming infected with the corona
virus the man's
I've also ingested the substance and is
under critical care the toxic ingredient
they consumed was not the medication
form of chloroquine used to treat
malaria in humans instead it was an
ingredient listed on a parasite
treatment for fish so it's not it's not
the same thing at all it's actually a
very different thing I think President
Trump I think conservatives I think we
would all agree don't ingest parasite
treatments for fish but the parasite
treatment for fish is not the medicine
that we're all talking about the left is
so desperate to prevent us from
recovering the left is so desperate to
prevent us from returning to normal both
socially and economically that they're
just publishing lies in the press you
often probably publish lies in the press
but you'd think they would be able to
rise above that kind of pettiness during
a pandemic enough is enough okay it is
becoming increasingly clear that many
forces on the left in this country do
not want a solution to the problem many
left-wing forces in this country seem to
want the problem to get worse because it
will give them a political advantage
this has gone too far you want some
evidence that this has gone too far
look no further than Dane County
Wisconsin now you know at the federal
level President Trump is said 15 days to
stop the virus that's going to expire on
March 30th just about we'll have to
reassess then but because we have a
federal system most of the response to
this has not been at the federal level
Democrats can't even pass a stimulus
package most of the response has been at
the state and local level so you know in
very liberal states California New York
we are basically locked down almost
entirely locked down other states and
localities not so much Dane Wisconsin
Dane County Wisconsin has put us all to
shame because not only are they locking
down and saying no groups of people and
no with private events and no religious
services and no nothing they've now put
a put a forum on the internet where you
can report your fellow citizens for
participating in any of these activities
you can send in an anonymous report so
it says online this forum may only be
used to report mass gatherings as
defined in the current order this is a
government order that are being held in
Dane County for mass gatherings outside
of Dane County please contact your local
law enforcement what are the types of
mass gatherings restaurant hotel and bar
okay movie theater okay private
gathering okay Jim Fitness okay and
religious center so now if you're in
Dane County Wisconsin and you see a
group of people going to worship God you
see a group of people holding a mass
having a church service you can report
them and they will be subject to
penalties by the civil government
cheeseheads it is time to revolt okay if
you are living in Dane County Wisconsin
you need to vote every single one of
these people out of office there needs
to be unrest I mean this is outrageous
this is insane you cannot comply with
this this this actually is tyranny you
know I'm loathe to throw the T word
around too much I try to keep relatively
calm when it comes to these political
debates but a forum put out by your
government to rat on fellow citizens for
worshiping God give me a freakin break
these politicians every single one who
signed off on this needs to be thrown
out of office and never employed again
this is absolutely outrageous we have
taken this too far and if if Dane County
Wisconsin is just a preview of what the
left wants to do in other counties then
we need to end this ASAP okay we can
protect public health we can take
precautions
without giving up everything that
matters to us in this country why is the
left so willing to do this as always for
answers to these questions of crazy
leftism we have to look to our wonderful
superiors in Hollywood
so indras Elba is the British actor
Idris Elba was just on Oprah explaining
why he thinks the corona virus is
attacking poor planet Earth Indra Selva
just tested positive for corona virus so
you had to Skype into Oprah's show Idris
Elba presents a religious view of why
the corona virus epidemic is taking
place and beneath all of that perhaps
there's a little bit of a financial
motive to has been taking a kick in you
know we've damaged our world and you
know it's no surprise that our world is
reacting to the human race there's no
surprise that a virus has been created
that is going to slow us down and
ultimately make us think differently
about our world and ourselves that's
like a real for me
that's a stand out thing that's very
obvious that this is almost like the
world's cry out to like hey hey hey be
kicking me you know what you're doing is
not good so I'll get rid of you as any
any any organism would do is try and get
rid of an infection and maybe this is
the world star so it's very obvious to
Idris Elba that the world is crying out
in attacking us it's very obvious to me
that the world is not crying out and
attacking us because the world is Iraq
interests Elba refers to the world as an
organism the world is not an organism is
a rock organisms live on that rock it is
a rock this is a very popular religion
on the left it's the religion of
pantheism to treat the physical world as
though it were God I mean you see this
all the time especially in the
environmentalist movement but even in
just the kind of vague hippie sentiments
that they throw around Mother Earth that
we've come from the earth our mother or
you know that the earth is crying out
because we've attacked it and it's
attacking us back first of all if the
earth really is conscious and attacking
us and we better fight back hard against
it right let's drink those plastic water
bottles let's use those plastic straws
but of course that's not what's
happening at all the earth is Iraq we
are on it and in this popular
environmentalist
legend the left is worshipping the rock
and this religion ultimately is anti
human because it prioritizes rocks above
all of us
that's the religious motive here there
is a more cynical motive though a more
in a furious explanation I think Indra
selbst is saying the reason we have
coronavirus is because of this mystical
period in which this mystical experience
where we have thrown plastic straws into
the ocean so the earth is giving us a
SARS like pandemic to kill us all off or
something that doesn't matter it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense I think we
have coronavirus because the Chinese
government gave it to us seems pretty
simple to me right coronavirus appears
somehow we're not exactly sure how
pretty close to the Wuhan Institute of
biology of all the cities in the world
of all the cities in China shows up
right near the place where they handle
all of these highly contagious diseases
and bio weapons so it just shows up
there but look let's say it's naturally
occurring let's say it came from a bat
right the Chinese government knows about
this on November 17th they don't tell
the world until the end of December if
China had reacted one week earlier they
could have reduced the spread by 66% two
weeks earlier they could have reduced by
86 percent three weeks earlier they
could have reduced by 95 percent but
they didn't do it so the Chinese
Communist government gave us this
disease why is Indra salba trying to
blame it on some weird pantheistic
voodoo rather than the obvious culprit
which is Communist China perhaps it is
because the Chinese government is
funding so much of Hollywood you know I
I spoke to some friends of mine who are
pretty high up in Hollywood who have
worked in Hollywood for a long time have
been in very very top rooms and very big
movies and they backed me up on this
they actually took me a little bit
further they told me details that I
simply didn't realize China owns so many
of our theaters they invest so heavily
in many of our big starts they've
invested in Indra Selva they've invested
it but it's not just a drizzle but it's
all of Hollywood they've invested in and
so Hollywood is loath to bite the hand
that feeds them you remember the NBA
had this controversy just a few months
ago one guy in the NBA sees fit to
defend the Hong Kong protesters the
whole NBA s to shut him down why because
the NBA as part of Hollywood as part of
our entertainment culture relies on
Chinese audiences not a great situation
to be in it's it's just so cynical I
mean I'd like to hope that the left has
these kind of crazy idea list
motivations as well like Idris Elba's
pantheistic religion but there would
seem to be a certain cynicism to all of
it to Chuck in Nancy's shutting down the
relief bill to the mainstream media
totally carrying water for China totally
misrepresenting the cure to Hollywood
doing basically the same thing at the
very least what we have to take away
from all of that is if our friends over
on the left are not taking this
seriously if the alarmists are not
taking this seriously
if the very people telling us we need to
shut down our economy for 9 months or 18
months or not taking this seriously why
the hell should we from the campaign
trail we also have to ask another
question where is Joe Biden have you
seen Joe Biden do you know where Joe
Biden's gone I don't know where Joe
Biden's gone you know I do think the
coronavirus needs to be taken seriously
right I don't think it needs to be taken
seriously in the way the left says it
does which means we need to shut down
the global economy but we should take
precautions try not to get sick if
you're at risk you should stay home
quarantine yourself wash your hands a
lot all the stuff that's totally common
sense I guess Joe Biden is doing that
because he's not on campaign trail he's
in a very at-risk group so Joe Biden is
now trying to film campaign messages
from his living room it looks absolutely
hilarious and the saddest part of all of
it is he seems to have even less energy
even less focus well he's campaigning
without any other distractions than he
did a few weeks ago if up the number of
responders dealing with the crush these
crushing cases and
and in addition to that in addition to
that we have to make sure that we we are
in a position that we are well let me
let me go the second thing I've spoken
up in it the president must use the
defense production Act
this is so embarrassing I'll cut it
there cuz you don't nobody needs to see
that he's losing his train of thought
this has been another advantage for the
left of the whole coronavirus epidemic
is nobody's talking about Joe Biden
anymore Joe Biden basically clinches the
nomination and then he disappears from
the campaign trail because we're all
focused on something else
look if Joe Biden could count on this
kind of distraction until November it's
his best chance of winning the
presidency this guy is not fit to be the
president okay I don't think he was ever
fit to be the president but he sure
ain't now and his best chance is to run
a front porch campaign to never leave
his his home and hope that he just wins
because of the chaos from coronavirus
and in the economy that people will
blame President Trump for we should not
allow them to take that much attention
off of Joe Biden now some other people
are trying to come out as much they can
during the corona virus epidemic and
give us all advice so while Joe Biden is
trying to hide or Hollywood celebrities
are trying to come forward I couldn't
finish the show today without this
inspiring message from Hollywood
specifically from Madonna who is taking
a bubble bath with rose petals all
around her telling us how to be safe in
the virus that's the thing about kovat
19 it doesn't care about how rich you
are how famous you are
how funny you are how smart you are
where you live how old you are hold on a
second hold on right there just like to
correct Madonna it very much does care
how old you are if you are over 80 or
over 70 or a much greater risk than if
you are 20 or 30 or under 9 or 10 years
old
so that's not true also it does care
about where you live if you live in
Wuhan or Milan you're much more likely
to get it than if you live in Fiji
anyway she goes on what amazing stories
you can tell it's the great equalizer
and what's terrible about it is what's
great about it it's terrible about it is
that Spain is all equal in many ways and
what's wonderful about it is that it's
made us all equal in many ways like I
used to say that the other human nature
every night we're all in the same boat
this [ __ ] goes down we're all going down
together we're all in the same boat now
inside of that boat some of us are in
beautiful bathtubs with rose petals all
around us with our zillion dollar
mansions but we're all in the same boat
together okay that Madonna video which
is getting a lot of ridicule obviously
that Madonna video is at least as
serious as Nancy Pelosi's coronavirus
Vil so like we're gonna attack Madonna
that's fine
Madonna's response is no more frivolous
than any other response we've seen from
the left before we go I have to get to
it this came out I think last Friday but
I I just don't want to miss it it's the
real it's the real cherry on top of the
Hollywood media Congressional Democrat
for volley Sunday and that is the
imagined video there's a video going
around of Hollywood store at stars all
in quarantine filming themselves singing
imagine that awful John Lennon Diddy and
him to communism they're singing it each
together to get us
through the pandemic take it away easy
if you try
[Music]
stop it right there these people are
professional entertainers they could not
even keep the same key for 9 seconds
they could network only listening to two
people sing and they get the key wrong
within nine seconds come on man high
school choir could keep the same key
they go on imagine all the people so one
question I have here is who half of
these people are I don't quite I mean
psy recognized Sarah Silverman there at
the end half of these people though like
there's some kid with long hair and he's
in a white hoodie I have no idea who
that guy is I'm not saying I have the
biggest podcast in the world but damn it
I should have been invited to do this
video then they finish it all off it
isn't hard to do nothing to kill or die
for and no religion too imagine all
[Music]
[Music]
okay I can't take any more obviously
this video is much much more sickening
than the Wuhan virus ever has been if
this is our response we need to stop
that response immediately I love by the
way that Hollywood's first first
reaction to a virus that comes from
Communist China and that is only spread
because of that communist government is
to sing an ode to communism which is
what imagine is perfect just that level
of obliviousness that we have come to
expect from our entertainers that that's
the response though I bring it up not
just to make fun of a bunch of Hollywood
people I bring it up I bring up
Madonna's video not just to make fun of
Madonna it's all of a piece the
Hollywood response the mainstream news
response the Congressional Democrat
responds it's all of a piece it's all
unserious so maybe it's time to take the
serious people more seriously serious
people including the President of the
United States the chief public health
expert during this dr. pouchy even a
piece in The New York Times written by a
professor from a very liberal academic
institution maybe we need to take a
harder look at that side of it the
people calling for alarm and shut down
or singing crazy Diddy's and bathing in
tubs full of rose petals and lying about
the medicine that might be able to stop
the virus the people who are saying
maybe we need to move on they seem a
little bit more serious to me that's our
show come on back tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]